so when i was at uni
i learned a lot about architecture but i
didn't learn
as much as i really thought it was only
when i got out into the real world and
started practicing
as an architect that i actually started
to learn a few bits and pieces that's
why today i really wanted to talk about
the
in-depth focus of roof construction
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
if you're new here firstly thank you so
much for joining me
on this channel we talk all things
architecture and technology
if that's something that interests you
make sure you smash that subscribe
button
because today we're talking about
archicad 24 and
roof construction so there were a lot of
things i didn't know as a grad and there
were definitely a lot more things that i
didn't know when i actually entered the
real world of architecture and practice
now today i wanted to talk to you guys
exactly how roof construction works
what the different elements are and what
you should know when you're documenting
on arcade 24.
if you are struggling with construction
documentation there is a link down below
to a construction checklist that i
personally use myself
and design myself for you guys to be
able to help you out
and as always there's also another link
just below for all of these awesome cut
shirts
now let's jump into today's tutorial and
turn around to these screens
okay so on the right hand side of my
screen i've got arcade 24
open and i've gone ahead and modeled a
very basic house
there is nothing to it it's couple walls
and a roof structure
but what i want to talk about is that
roof structure in itself
on top because what may seem like a very
simple roof construction of a hip and
valley roof
is actually a lot more complicated than
you might think on the left hand side of
my screen which i'll drag to the right
is a twin motion render of that exact
same project
now i'm going to use both the arc cad
and the twin motion files
just to give it a bit of variation and
show you a bit of a nicer graphics along
the process so if we jump back to arcade
24 straight away you'll see that i have
a hip and valley roof structure
on top of my brick walls now in archicad
24 you can simply construct any roof
structure by going to the roof tool
selecting the hip and valley geometry
and then just tracing around
the actual walls that you need to
construct there are a number of
different elements going on in this
very simple image in front of us for
example at the front of this house we
have what's called a gable roof
it's the difference between this flat
edge here of the roof and this
gable end on the exact opposite we have
something completely different
we have a gable that is flush with a
brick wall against it
so at the front you'll see that with
this gable roof
we have what is called a barge fascia so
at the front of this roof you're going
to see what we call a gable barge
so if we zoom in a little bit closer you
can see this
little board here that goes all the way
along the front
and that's what we depict as a barge
board now if we were open up the
settings and being able to change each
individual roof edge
this is ci tools roof covering so if you
do want to download and store that you
can it is an added expense to arcade 24
but i found it phenomenal
you can see at the front here we have
our gable barge which is looking at
this edge here now if we were to change
that to a gutter
and go okay we would see that no gutter
is actually created and
all it does is take away our barge board
at the front
so if we open up that setting again we
can also have the apron option
which you'll see takes away the front
barge completely
and leaves us with a flashing that wraps
up at 90 degrees
i'll go into the apron option a little
bit further on the other side of the
roof
to explain why that's important but on
this side of the roof
we are going to be using a barge board
now if you're thinking when do i need to
use a gutter when do i need to use an
apron and when do i need to use a barge
it's actually quite simple so the barge
is always going to be at the end where
you can physically see it
so for example on this side here it's a
gable so we can see the barge
if we go around this side of the roof is
exposed
so again we have another barge if it's
exposed
to the public eye you're going to have a
barge
if the roof falls down and there's an
edge you're always going to have a
gutter of some sorts
most of the time you can't have it just
left open and
falling down unless you're in a cyclone
prone area but in most instances you
will need some sort of gutter or some
sort of water catchment system
to be able to control the water flow
from the roof to the ground
and finally there is the apron option
that is allowed on these settings
and the apron option is another simple
one as long as you know the differences
between them
an apron simply wraps up at a 90 degree
angle most of the time it doesn't have
to be 90 degrees
against a solid surface so that when it
rains it comes down
onto this apron and then falls on to the
roof
it's basically protecting this roof and
this wall structure from water
penetrating through
just like an apron would protect you
when you spill food all over you so
that's a good way to remember when you
need to use an apron
versus when you need to use a gutter and
also when you need to use a barge
now this roof in itself is quite simple
it's a hip and valley roof like i
mentioned before but there's a number of
different
elements going on in this structure
itself so if we look
down this line here in the center where
these two roofs
join and they start to fall downwards we
call that a valley
now you make all this different
terminology around the world but in
australia we call that a valley
and on the top right here is what we
call a ridge
they're the two main structural
components that you need to know of a
hip and valley roof
it's simply a valley where it joins and
falls and it's a ridge where it meets
like a mountain
again these two colorbond sheets here on
the left and the right hand side of this
gable roof
would meet at a whatever angle degree
this roof is i think it's 30 degrees
and then obviously because it's a
corrugated finish you would need some
sort of capping
along the top to be able to protect all
that water not getting in
and under and then leaking into your
house underneath so now if we jump back
to twin motion just to give it a bit
more flair and a bit more
architectural styling we'll see that we
have a render that's quite nice
it's a modern brick house with a hip and
valley roof
we can see all the elements that we
discussed we can see that ridge capping
that hip capping
we can see the barge board at the front
which has been
brushed with a brushed black metal
finish
we can see our gutters we can see our
dart pipes
and for example our gutters aren't
showing up so this is a quick little tip
if we go out of full screen mode open
this
select our gutter material go to
settings
and make it two-sided all of a sudden we
can see
all of our gutter so that's a really
good and handy trick
if you're stuck in twin motion and can't
see those curves
or any material that's undulating and
changing shape
if we continue to spin around we can see
our barge board on that exposed side of
the roof
and going all the way to the back near
our rendered wall
we can see our apron as well so it's a
very simple concept
that if the water runs down it'll fall
onto that rape apron off of the apron
onto the corrugated roof
and into the gutter itself
now the last thing that we have to pay
attention in a roof construction
is the actual down pipes so the down
pipes depending on how far the roof
extends might have to bend a little bit
to reach back to the wall and be fixed
to the wall
or they might be able to go straight
down if that roof
is something of this nature where it's
just flush to the edge of the brickwork
one thing that you have to keep in mind
when designing is that you're going to
need a downpipe everywhere you have a
gutter
so as you can see on this 3d render here
we have one two three four four very
visible
down pipes on this facade itself
which means i couldn't have created a
corner window
that wrapped all the way from this wall
all the way across returned here and
then ran all the way back
you just wouldn't physically be able to
return that water anyway
obviously there's a series of ways that
you can hide these down pipes they can
go into the cavity
they can run into the wall they can be
shifted they can be combined
and they don't necessarily need this
many but i'm just showing this many for
the purposes of argument
we have a series of these downpipes that
would impeach on our facade
and it's important that we do show them
in these renders so people
when they get a sense of their house go
don't come to final construction go oh
that's an ugly downpipe going right
through the middle of where i thought
would be a beautiful brick wall
besides from a gable roof looking a lot
nicer than the edge of a hip and valley
roof like this side
it also gives us the added benefit of
not requiring any down pipes along the
front fascia
so because we're looking at this house
directly on and that would be the main
facade
we don't need to see any down pipes
running straight through that beautiful
facade
instead we can hide our down pipes on
the left and right hand side
of that gable roof so gable rooms aren't
always an architectural desire to have
them as an architectural styling
sometimes it is a roof construction idea
so we can push away those down pipes and
really focus on the architecture instead
of all the water management
and all the nitty-gritty details now one
thing you'll notice is that these
downpipes are going directly into the
ground and just falling
in australia what we would do is
actually we would connect them to a soak
well
and they would run underground and
disappear to a soak well
somewhere far away from the house this
is because if we run our downpipes
directly to the ground and let all that
water just pond
on the ground eventually this house
formation
right under this downpipe will start to
fall away
crack and break and the foundations will
become weakened
so what we want to do is really force
that water away from the house as much
as we can
and that's why these down pipes go
straight into the ground and disappear
you would see some sort of stormwater
great in real life but for the purpose
of this we're just modeling it very
simply to get the argument of roof
construction across
underneath the roof you'll see that it
wraps around and has this
black soffit lining so we can completely
get rid of this soffit it could be on
the rake it could be flat
depending on how we like it if i fly
into this house you'll notice the
difference between the soffit and the
roof construction
so the soffit is just the lining
underneath the exposed
roof basically it has to be some sort of
water resistant material something like
fiber cement or fiber cement sheeting
that can resist
any water penetration going through it
and we can ensure that our house stays
watertight the whole time
these sofas don't necessarily have to be
flat they can be raking like i said
before which
gives you the same look as this it that
at the end of the day
is just an architectural styling and how
you would like to finish off
the edges most of the time it's just the
flat soffit
at the edge here where the roof passes
the edge of the wall
because it's a nice finish that's not
detailed correctly it would definitely
extend
to the edge of this wall but we're not
going into so much detail
on a gable roof it would look definitely
like this you would want to rake it you
definitely wouldn't want to box it out
it would look horrible and it would be
very impractical
and hard to construct so if you do have
that
raking finish where it's exposed on the
edges you will have that raking
soffit as well now if you ever get
confused on what all these elements are
you can open up
the archicad settings so if we go into
arc cad select one of our
roof sheeting materials and go to the
roof shedding dialog box
you'll see that there is an abundance of
different
sections here that we can go through so
if we go from the cladding material we
can see that it's showing the corrugated
cladding type
we have all sorts of different materials
we can have ribbed cladding we can have
uh shingles we can have tiles
we can have a whole bunch of different
things colorbond is
one of the most common in australia so
we're just showing colorbond for the
purposes of this video
then we can show our gable wall ends we
can change all these settings we can
continue to go through we can have the
finials
at the top which would be a nice little
architectural
feature right at the top of this gable
it shows all sorts of different framing
of how that sits
on the actual roof structure i made a
video about that actually last week so
if you go back and check that out
you'll see timber frame construction and
how it all goes together
and that includes the roof and purlins
and the framing
we have our edge boards which is what we
were talking about here there are barge
boards which we can adjust in settings
and styles
we have our fascia boards which is the
actual board sitting underneath the
barge capping
and finally we have the barge board
itself so
on that front barge there is three
multiple elements that we can adjust
and it continues to go around for the
ridge board the soffits
the flashings and so on so if you do
ever get confused
of what a single element is you can come
back into this
go through all of these and actually
learn in more detail
and that's pretty much it guys all you
need to know about roof construction it
is very simple
but the terminology is very important
that you understand because if you go in
here
and all of a sudden just don't put a
gutter on there you put a barge board
you put an apron over here and you do
something like this
you're going to end up with a horrible
looking roof that doesn't work
and the builders are going to be
thinking what kind of idiot is
putting together this set of drawings
they don't know anything about
construction
and i'm just going to go ahead and build
whatever i like
so it's pivotal that you know these very
minor details
but they are very critical to you
excelling in your career
as an architect as a designer as
whatever you're watching this video from
but that is the general basis of roof
construction
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below and as
always i'll see you
next monday